is home to vic and yolanda flores who
previously owned another mexican
restaurant that failed
they wanted to try again but didn't have
the money so they asked yolanda's
daughter patty to use her credit and
savings i'm 100 owner on paper
but my stepfather vic controls
everything all right
he listened to me he didn't listen to my
daughter he does whatever he wants to do
we have to discuss the problem and
here's
go
i thought this was a big opportunity but
from day one it turned out to be a
disaster it's tough i can't chill
initially we were busy
and then after a while it just the
numbers started dwindling is it normally
this quiet so i said maybe we should
make some changes and he said
everything's fine i've been thinking of
changing the menu but my husband say
people like it
for how many people
we spend so much time just looking out
the window staring at each other so how
many tables are there
i don't know figuring what can we do to
bring people in it's like the blind
leading the blind
he always thinks that he's right he'll
decorate the way he wants to
it looks like tijuana threw up in here
he has a stuffed chili pepper that he
moves around named manuel
the most bothers me
is that
my daughter
has run her credit i have to go cover a
bounce checker of something
she has problem in her marriage
i i just feel very guilty that i
put paddy and this position i never
thought it was going to be this bad
well i realized it was bad we can't pay
our bills i resent my mother
i think she put her husband before me
and it's hurtful
[Music]
i'm just hoping to god that jeff ramsey
will help us and
that big will listen to him otherwise
our personal lives are going to be
changed drastically
[Music]
right
there's the sign but grill
what the [ __ ] is that
maybe
i'm too late
grill yesterday's sunrise
oh dear oh dear how are you very well
indeed thank you grill 303 or another
yes that's all right okay good yes all
right nice to see you
nice to meet you i thought it was too
late i thought it was the new restaurant
already
oh well we don't change the the little
logo on the front you haven't changed
the logo on the front now and it's been
like that foreign year and a half a year
and a half yeah okay
right
jesus what's that
this is a new uh favorites of migrating
that we have in here
so it's complimentary i've been into
attacking wow yeah so you don't have to
buy for drinks you just come up here and
well you know when the people they're
coming in we try to be you know give you
something to appetize her to start
too strong
tequila
right let's put some warmth on my balls
okay yeah sit down please excellent done
so that's free
right wow look at the size of this place
so how many seats have you got there 120
120 120 yeah wow
how many is booked for lunch
two tables
okay what would you recommend
the combination number one number one
one tackle you have one taco one burrito
and one enchilada okay yeah i'll try one
of the fajitas as well okay i'm hoping
that chef ramsay kicks week is bad
what is that
looks like i've got a sticker on my menu
just trying to peel it off and it's
bugging me
[Music]
they aren't a mexican
cookie
what is under there
the name of the
what name is that it was uh my another
restaurant
i used to have
yes so you brought the
old menus from the old restaurant into
the new restaurant and stuck
some sellotape on exactly
yes and is that restaurant still open no
with clothes and you called it fiesta
sunrise as opposed to fiesta garibaldi
curry yes uh i'm really confused for it
same chef center same ingredients same
ingredients you brought the ingredients
from the old restaurant into this recipe
oh well you know different we buy you
this is your combination okay lovely
it's very hot be careful
this is the burrito here it's hard to
see that looks like someone's been sick
on my plate
chicken's so dry it tastes like it's
been cooked weeks ago the beef
excuse me
it's impossible to swallow
i can see he didn't like it
wow how old is the rice it looks like
it's
left over from christmas look this uh
yesterday
yesterday
how did you know that
i checked in the kitchen
check again for me please thank you
it looks older than [ __ ] me
absolutely [ __ ] dreadful how's it
going
he hated the rice
why it's old how old is it they're
disgusting you know basically taste of
[ __ ] i always feel very embarrassed
first of all there was the menu
and the more important thing that was
the food that
is gross oh now it's my fault no i'm not
just asking you oh no so we bought the
glasses from gary baldy as well we
invested a lot of money into this we
should have known this [ __ ] a year and a
half ago
maybe that's the key when you're coming
to fiesta sunrise stop off at the
tequila bar and get drunk
and then enjoy the food you don't want
to listen to me
hi hello how are you bro thank you how
are you both good i'm patty and your
husband and wife i'm step daughter okay
sorry i thought you said your partner
excuse me
okay
likewise and first name is yolanda
yolanda
right i was the preacher that was
delicious
sad that was the only thing that i
enjoyed um let's go over to the bar have
a little chat yes i'm hoping chef ramsay
will convince vic that change is good
you know i think they're stuck in their
ways we should have stepped in a long
time ago now it just seems like this is
the end of our rope hopefully we can
make some type of changes to save this
business
all three of you paid for the business
these two
youtube pay for the business
and this man runs it he ruins it ruins
it runs it runs it runs it or ruins it
yeah so far it's [ __ ] ruined yeah
did you have anything to do with the old
business i didn't no no
i didn't you did
so that restaurant failed and then you
came to run this one for your wife and
your stepdaughter yeah but before you
left you grab the chicken the men using
the glasses no just the menu okay i'm
trying to get my head round this if you
all own it and he's running it why
aren't you involved my opinion is i
think he just wanted us to finance him a
restaurant i put a lot out here i put my
credits my home i borrowed money from my
father-in-law it's not important to him
it's not important to him to make things
right with me what does it take to break
even how much do we need to take a week
to break even 90 000 a month a month
yeah a month so
22 grand a week we do a third of that so
you're losing half a million dollars a
year what's the debt that's 850 850 000
and you've only been open for 18 months
right
what in the [ __ ] have you been doing
no i'm the big guy in here everything is
going wrong
the beacon and me
i will see you later thank you ladies
see you later vic
that's embarrassing right now they're
all blaming each other and it's bloody
obvious that vic has run the place into
the ground but how can the women
complain about that if they haven't put
the time and effort in this place so
personally they're all to [ __ ] blame
[Music]
this restaurant's run with dysfunctional
management and i'm dying to find out how
the kitchen actually functions because
how is it possible for someone to cook
food so bland as that
tonight i'm going to find out but i'm
not eating again that's for sure
he likes one appetizer
okay
wow look at the size of this kitchen
it's huge
ambrosia ambrosia gordon okay in there
what's that in there
the tournament holy crap
oh [ __ ] when was the last time this was
cleaned out yesterday and what's this
they're the right the famous rice yeah
that's the fresh rice is it
oh i gotta serve the old ship yeah
what's this one where's that one from
yesterday which one's the first one
[Music]
i was disappointed a big and the cooks
it seems like i see this place for the
first
time enchiladas okay
[Music]
when were these done
yesterday
yesterday
[ __ ] off fake please they weren't done
yesterday
okay you can ask him his own language
and ask him very very quickly when were
these cooks
also this one for last week
of course they're from last week they
don't look like they're [ __ ]
lunchtime do they
[Music]
oh my god look at the fat look
why is there so much disgusting fat on
there
what's wrong with those chips
i think only one
you take them from the table back into
the drawer did you see that they come
back from the table and you put them
back into the drawer he said he didn't
touch it he touched one he said he
touched one you're not supposed to [ __ ]
we're like a bunch of children that are
doing
the wrong thing
what are these
vic
yeah chap these were fresh chives sell
by date
five
months old
where you found them i found them in the
[ __ ] fridge smell them
vic look let me just show you something
what is that
i'm getting nervous now talk to me what
is this
that's the thing what you think that's
the fish you're using
oh [ __ ] me smell that in there
is this today's fish
no um no
the fish that was really scary because
it was smelling bad already i just
couldn't believe it
where's patty yeah have a look at this
oh my god look how crispy and curled up
it is just touch that oh it's it it's
like solidified
what's this here there's the steak
why is it all wrapped up in tin foil
look at the color of it it's
oxidized and what's that in there
that's pork
what have you done to it why is it all
stuck in there with blood at the bottom
of the tray why is that
how old is this stuff yesterday
yesterday he said friday
look at that
oh my gosh
when's all this from friday he took it
out friday oh
everything's friday
look let me just show you something look
how green and slime it is that's from
friday look
look at that that's from friday look at
my fingers
friday
look
look
there you go that's from friday how do
you say this in spanish this is not
healthy no muy saludable thank you
what is going on in here
a hungry cat would walk away from that
i was mortified i felt embarrassed for
letting this go on for so long while
customers in the dining room continue to
eat sub-par food chef ramsay's kitchen
investigation
what is going on here what's that the
burritos what's that one the chicken of
enchiladas oh how
oh my god what's that that was the
grumpy
ground beef
half of its [ __ ] fat you idiot
it's fatter than you
i felt satisfied that finally somebody
called him out on his [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
what's that
the bin oh how
it's like a cement mixer
are you [ __ ] stupid
who's controlling this i am chef you are
you
are a walk in disaster
now i'm feeling like stupid
lift it up
the fridge is full of [ __ ]
it it's disgusting
i wasn't here on saturday but what were
they expecting [ __ ] 10 000 customers
for lunch paddy i'm [ __ ] disgusted
yolanda that's a joke i understand i
don't want people to get sick and i
don't want them to spread the word that
food is bad here
overstaffed
underworked
[ __ ] food
i wouldn't trust you running a bath
let alone a [ __ ] restaurant
you must be out of your tiny mind
i don't care for your restaurant
i want to take that out there i dave
take it out there go on give it to them
yeah there you go with me look at me why
wouldn't you take it out there
that's embarrassing it's embarrassing
why are you serving it you don't [ __ ]
care why why because you're serving that
and trying to charge people money for
that that's why you don't care i care
for you you don't care [ __ ]
no [ __ ] way
[ __ ]
ladies and gentlemen
i'm so sorry
but we're stopping service
shocked by disgrace what is going on
here after disgrace how did you say this
in spanish this is not healthy after
disgrace i want to take that out there
chef ramsay had seen enough and took
matters into his own hands you don't
[ __ ] care
ladies and gentlemen
i'm so sorry
but we're stopping
service everything you've had to drink
eat so far is all on the house
sir
that thing in your hands put it down if
you've just seen where it's come from
like i have you wouldn't be eating it
very sorry
close up
no pill anywhere
i was like the hell are you doing you
can do that to my customers by the way
there's your refi beans on the way out
have a look at it
[Music]
my god this garbage pocket
i couldn't believe it and seeing all
these people walking out of the
restaurant
it was like
this is the end
i think vic got a dose of reality he
walked around like he was untouchable
so i was relieved that finally somebody
else
told him that he was responsible for a
lot of this
while vic supervises the cleanup
[Music]
chef ramsay spends his time with a woman
who is torn between her daughter and her
husband
what i'm really concerned about is
what's happening to your daughter
how did it start because something's
blurring for me my credit was messed up
so we use party for a credit
too she was clean
yeah
you've destroyed your daughter's credit
because now she has no choice i mean yes
you and her are in the [ __ ] my darling
i know sometimes i can sleep at night
do you love rick
i do but it's different now you know
know before you came here
i see if this doesn't work i don't think
you and i could be
together anymore
who's more important your daughter or
your husband
my daughter
at this point you know i realized it's
not enough really a choice
right now the only way to show paddy to
how much you care is to get involved yes
to help turn this business around
now you tell me what to do
another marriage that is affected by
fiesta sunrise's debt is patty and don's
usually don drops her off to avoid
running into vic but on this occasion
patty asked him to come in and meet chef
ramsay good to see you
i want to save the relationship with my
husband because he's really angry at me
for getting involved and it just seems
to be spiraling out of control
[Music]
obviously
paddy explained i'm absolutely furious
in terms of the way the kitchen was run
the way the place has been abused and i
can't believe a guy
like vic would try to do so much
under your own eyes without even you
knowing anything about it are you aware
of what's been going on we fight all the
time about it yeah he saw it coming and
i said no he wouldn't do this he
wouldn't do that and
he said he's he's not who he appears to
be he's taking advantage of you and your
mom you know if mum admitted last night
that you had a clean credit record oh my
goodness so that got it i got abused
that's in the crowd one thing i'm mad at
you know money um can always be
made and we paid back the credit he just
never paid the the monthly payment on
do you think you can get more involved
in terms of support mechanism oh sure
when i saw dan my reaction it was like
oh
this is patricia's husband it's nothing
to do in the business
i have
sit down
i'm trying to get to the bottom of it
vic i'm trying to understand
the madness and to how we've been
operating when you knew you're borrowing
all that money from family why won't you
be more honest about where the money was
going
you know god's not clear
now it is but when i asked him are you
going to give patty any money no no i
don't think so that really doesn't cut
it
i believe don's trying to stand up for
me he feels that big walks all over me
you're not going to give my wife any
money
you have to go on something i paid your
mortgage here you jerk off one month i
paid 50 000
douche bags you don't even have a job i
don't have a job what are you doing pal
i got a job oh please you're hunting
you're fishing this is your job i have
downtime i do what i want i pay my bills
pal i pay my bills in fact i pay your
bills too
[Music]
outside
while patty and don were discussing
their financial situation are you aware
what's been going on we fight all the
time about it yeah vic joined the
conversation sit down accusations were
made you don't even have a job and don
and vic were at war i don't have a job i
pay my bills in fact i pay your bills
too
you can't start talking about that you
can't start telling that you can't this
ain't even half this [ __ ]
i'm upset
my husband really wanted to help and
he's probably gonna be mad at me for
putting him in a situation like this
also so in a way i'm not
i'm here to help this place turn around
but to make this work
all three of you have to work as a team
while the family cools off chef ramsay
heads to the kitchen to come up with a
game plan to fix the restaurant's
biggest problem
the food
oh my god
[Music]
what in the [ __ ] is that
[Music]
that
is a [ __ ] joke
victor
right ladies
i want us all to get involved in doing
something together yeah so i wanted a
little fun element you make a burrito
you make a burrito you make a burrito
and the best one goes on the menu
tonight that's what i wanted to do
i couldn't do it because of these little
[ __ ] here
look at them
oh my god
i'm so sick to my stomach i want to
throw up because i have coffee here
earlier i don't know if the roach went
through my cup i didn't know about this
problem either two dishwashers
two prep cooks who's cleaning around
here
do they seriously put food on those
plates
vic's here seven days a week i don't
know
how he didn't realize the problems in
the kitchen can't you see these
i'm trying to move forward i'm trying to
get going but every time i put my foot
on the ladder i get knocked back
did you know this was like this
i noticed i noticed but uh
yeah
we're gonna have to do something we
cannot open i need an exterminator here
how can i start in attempting to cook
when the place is festered with
cockroaches i didn't expect this i don't
think it could get worse i don't even
know what could make it worse at this
point
after chef ramsay's dirty discovery he
immediately called in an exterminator
i have no idea things were that bad
lucky how i'm pulling my hair out now
i'm sorry but you're running the place
sorry are you so stupid
where do i go vic
i'll be embarrassed with chip around
here i don't think that uh
we can make it in the restaurant
you can't run a [ __ ] russian like
that you think i'm not i'm [ __ ]
embarrassed you should be [ __ ]
embarrassed
i'm not putting one foot in that place
since that place is [ __ ] clean
yes
you're right
now you start getting those guys
cleaning yes
for some [ __ ] pride
do you understand the word pride yes
[Music]
it's not possible does someone have his
head so far in his [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] me
[Music]
i was feeling so depressed because all
the pressure that i have right now in
the restaurant and everybody picking
everything about me
you know he always thought he was right
now he finally
knows
all these mistakes
very sorry i'm very sorry
i don't mean to hurt your feelings and i
don't mean to hurt danny's feelings
very sorry
[Music]
after taking time to reassess the
situation and allow the exterminator to
finish chef ramsay returns more
determined than ever
we are not giving up to understand we
cannot give up
tonight we're going to open the place
has been cleaned we're prepping up now
and in under two hours time we'll be in
a position to open up
and then we work it together yes sir are
you gonna listen yes
[Music]
due to last night's shutdown chef ramsay
was unable to experience a normal dinner
service tonight with the old food a
thing of the past he can finally observe
the staff at work
tonight
it's all about fresh food everything we
prepped this morning we cooked tonight
fresh yes
fresh what is it
louder
you may be small but you've got a big
pair of lungs fresh fresh they speak
english they're just being clever by
ignoring me yes
yeah yeah i know that
[Music]
what do you guys like to
drink the chicken cheetos and one beef
enchiladas thank you
with customers in the restaurant chef
ramsay is anxious to impress them with
something fiesta sunrise has never had
fresh food
bloody hell
get me yolanda please
[ __ ] you now
yolanda you cook at home don't you yes
yeah what's wrong with this
absolutely right it's mush we've got
four chefs in the line not one of them
can cook rice
thick cooks don't even know what they're
doing i realize how bad it is today i
think you should start spending some
time in here can you cook rice now
yolanda yes sir
[ __ ] [ __ ] golf ball
it's been a while huh
a little hungry with the rice disaster
the kitchen is now backed up and the
customers are getting restless four
chefs on the line yeah it doesn't seem
to be happening fast yeah can you speed
up a little bit more i'm starving i just
wish i had my food yeah soon guys you
have four people over here we have to
start moving what is this guys doing
they don't even know who's
who's the leader over there we're
finished with our meals and the rest of
our table hasn't even received their
meals yeah
service please
pass it over
what's those black bits coming from the
from the tub
on the top of the broiler jesus christ
almighty when was the last time the
broiler was cleaned
the chips that now is they are crazy now
and it is like this place is half full
what are you going to do when it's
crowded and there's people waiting
outside
this is unbelievable what the [ __ ]
happening when was the broiler cleaned
last gentleman if he [ __ ] tells me
friday one more time i'll boil him
every sunday my [ __ ] ass this is out
of control i mean you got food i'm sure
that fishy food i've got four chefs that
can't cook [ __ ] rice soot all over
the food what is going on
[ __ ] me you're supposed to put salt on
the food not a [ __ ] soot that's a
joke you're going you're going to just
leave
nothing on there you can't employ these
guys one can't [ __ ] clean one can't
cook rice
i never imagined how bad this restaurant
was doing
i don't know what else could happen
i cannot come to terms with what the
[ __ ] happening
[Music]
on the heels of another dreadful dinner
service chef ramsay knows he's running
out of time to save this restaurant hard
day today
what we took tonight
couldn't even afford to pay for the
staff
that's how it is every day tonight is a
perfect example that you're digging
yourselves a bigger hole
we're tightening the noose around our
necks
i i
i've never been in this situation before
i'm now gonna start taking drastic
measures
we need help
that has helped
a lot of help
i'm going back to new york city now yeah
i have got to think of you know an idea
we're screwed
i'm this far from giving up
[Music]
chef ramsay stayed up most of the night
in new york city trying to think of
something or someone to help salvage
fiesta sunrise
he returned the next day reinvigorated
with a comprehensive plan
right good morning good morning come
round
after last night's dinner service
this
place needs help definitely
i have an expert okay that i've taken
care of that's going to be here
to help you
she has the number one mexican
restaurant in manhattan currently she's
from mexico and she seriously knows her
mexican cuisine
say hello please
juliette valesteros come and say hello
please like this is yolanda yeah one of
the owners if i got the call from chef
ramsey i got very excited i will only do
this for him vic they're ganging up on
you now one two three four against one
now you're outnumbered big boy
i was pleasantly surprised when chef
ramsay introduced julieta because we
really need the help with the kitchen in
good hands next chef ramsay reveals the
work his design team did to modernize
the restaurant oh my god come through
come through come through
now
look at it
we got rid of the clutter the ugly white
banquet chairs have gone look what you
can see now when you look down through
there it matches perfectly look
at the tablecloths oh my god
i love it i'm in shack the shutters
beautiful all the crap gone off the
ceiling the walls have been done they're
glad
stunning beautiful
now you have one beautiful mexican
restaurant
chef ramsay is unbelievable i can't
believe that he worked all night to do
all this
i used to get dizzy walking in here i
used to turn my stomach and now i feel
calm
and it looks like a place you'd want to
stay and hang out and spend some time
take it look at it i love my new
decoration
i love my chairs
i love my new place
thank you very much i just want you
to run it yeah with your wife with your
daughter and run it as a team that's all
i want i promise to you after this
no more mistakes
thank you for coming i appreciate it
having updated the look okay chef ramsay
moves on to the most significant change
in his master plan for saving the
restaurant we've brought in an expert
for the kitchen we've revamped the
dining room and now the most important
change that will be significant in
turning this business around and that's
the menu
do you like the new cover
no no good because that's what it's not
gonna be there we go
that's what the menu is gonna be
simple elegant easy to read easy to
control and maintain consistent
standards
ah have a quick look
i'm very excited
i'm happy
beautiful menu read over the menu i'm
gonna spend some time in the kitchen
with juliet yes okay let's come on
in order to ensure a successful relaunch
chef julieta stays on top of everything
and everyone in the kitchen
just crispy enough to be like to have a
crunch on your mouth but don't overcook
them
[Music]
i honestly never ever expected to be
here tonight every launch night what a
[ __ ] week the toughest so far so
now they have to pull it off they may
have the best mexican chef from
manhattan but it's up to them now
everything's here they've got to do it
let's see our meat oh look that's
beautiful now that you've got it you run
it and i'll be watching the service
tonight is crunch time this restaurant
has to have a successful service tonight
okay anything to say i hope we work
together as a team because i want
something to be proud of and i'm proud
of my family and
i'm happy everything has changed good
ready ready we're opening in five
minutes smile it's good
almost i think it's as big as it can
you're like a sumo wrestler upside down
smile
with a contemporary new look and
simplified menu the success of fiesta
sunrise now rests on the staff i'm
excited but i just want everything to go
okay so i hope they could pull this off
do you want an appetizer we're done
we're gonna take the guacamole
[Music]
it's for a kid it's for a little girl so
don't put any peppers
they need somebody to be in charge
they need guidance but they're willing
to learn
medium rare yes
[Music]
chef
it says kind of cold it went in oh come
on
julieta what the hell they said it's
cold cold yeah because it's hanging
around okay uno
nuevos por favor
everything's set up
everything's set up so you know this is
idiot proof and they still can't execute
it it's quite a worry
come on guys
something's burning yeah yeah they
burned the nachos they burnt naturals
what's going on guys please
how the [ __ ] do we burn natural
holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
what's this naturals flambe after a
shaky start
the pressure is now on vic
you get the restaurant running smoothly
this is excellent it's very good
the presentation is beautiful
good
what do you think about the sunset i
like this there's a nice texture thank
you
oh my god
i'm very excited i'm very happy for the
first time i see the people they're
smiling they're talking good things
about the restaurants what's special
about the food
chicken i really like the cafe this is
delicious thank you very much thank you
for the first time since it opened
fiesta sunrise is functioning properly
but they have one more hurdle to clear
before the night can be considered a
success i just have a phone call the
mayor of niagara coming the mayor yeah
the mayor hi yeah great great so he's
arriving for dinner tonight it's great
fantastic
we had the honor of having our local
mayor
visit us
hi how are you
good i was a little nervous because i
wanted him to enjoy our new food and
recommend it because that's some
exposure locally
hello senores thank you for coming can i
go for something appetizer we'll get one
of each episode okay oh yeah that'd be
good i'll put it all out
vic
make sure that there's okay make sure
there's a jolly time yep
what is this taquitos appetizer
yeah
i'm coming back
it was excellent food we had a great
evening tonight i would absolutely come
here again
[Music]
thank you forget that you're welcome
with dinner coming to a close and the
mayor satisfied fiesta sunrise finally
saw a glimmer of hope can you believe we
made it to tonight yeah extraordinary i
don't even know where to begin thanking
chef ramsay he came to me as a gift
because i was really at the end of my
role and he brought back
happiness
between all of us and i can never thank
him enough
[Music]
i honestly never ever ever thought we're
gonna make it to tonight you know
everybody
had to wake up to get where we are
now yes joe
and vic
vic vic vic
after all the mistakes you made and all
the crap you're telling me tonight
[Music]
you're great
i was impressed with your performance
tonight i'll be honest i was nervous the
tables all the customers everywhere
they're giving a good compliments about
the food good i was like so happy for
the first time since i arrived i got to
see your passion and your hunger to keep
this place alive
that's what it's going to take
and i'd like to say that tonight would
not be of any significant improvement
without the help of julietta thank you
forget that you're welcome we're doing
this to give this place a hope we all
need to work as a team and as a family
julietta thank you personally thank you
thank you very much indeed
okay
go back a week when i arrived i didn't
know if i was in the right place the
signs with grill 303 i can understand
what the hell what's going on here i
thought i'd drive too late
okay come outside
now
when we walk into the car park yes
here's something that each and every one
of your customers saw tonight
yes we did change it so when they park
in front of the restaurant they know
where they're eating
what's it called yeah i can't hear you
yes that's all right i still can't hear
you
all right
girls make sure it stays up there we
stay they want to stay over there fiesta
sunrise
got one more this way oh my god
wow oh my god you did it
of the mall that's right in front of
them all every day
25 000 cars go past this restaurant how
could all those people drive by every
day for 18 months
and you not take advantage of that
are you mad
i'm happy
[Laughter]
everybody drove past here tonight saw
that
i'm not kissing you yeah i don't know
okay let's go
okay
this is
my american dream and i think it's going
to be one of the best mexican
restaurants in town
keep it fresh thank you very much thank
you
[Music]